هاي مهنه بدات من تقريبا من 180 سنه في
العائله عنا وانطلقت كانت بدايه انطلاقتها
من الطفيله الشبيه الاردنيه هي معروفه
كقطعه من جميع الدول العربيه انها هي
الشبريه او السلاح الاردني
اللي يستخدمه للدفاع عن النفس والذبح
والترجيع اشياء كما هو معروف
والشبريه المحيسني او بيسموها دقه محيسن
بنسبه لاسم العائله عنا
فاحنا شبرين تتميز باللطافه بالشكل الانيق
بالقوه بالمتانه تبعتها من حيث الفولاذ من
حيث المعدن من المستخدم فيها من حيث طريقه
تصنيع والتشطيب ودايمومتها لفتره طويله هي
عباره عن مجموعه قديمه جدا عندي منها من
195380 لل 75 يعني هذا المجموعه لقيتها من
شغل همم والدي اعمامي وجدي
مخلوط مصنوع من القرم نصل مصنوع من
الفولات بطول ما يعادل الحوالي ال 15 سم
[موسيقى]
للشبريه حوالي 30 سم
وعن مراحل تصنيع الشبريه تبدا من همم
الحجر
بعد تركيب
تمام
والاصفر حتى يصلح هذا الشكل
[موسيقى]